so you've got your book there and I hope
you have a ruler or you can borrow from
a friend you will actually need your
ruler as a ruler today not just as a
straightedge
so in case you didn't know the
difference in a ruler a straightedge a
ruler can measure things here's a
diagram
I'd like you to create but what I'd like
you do is actually try to make your
diagram a little bit different to mine
and a little bit different to the person
next to you this is what you need to
include it's the same one two three
parallel lines and then these two guys a
e and B F both of which are not parallel
and cut along the three parallel lines
those are the transversal okay so what
about you do is create a three parallel
lines have them some distance apart
create a set it again if they are
parallel then they will not cut across
the jaws which are you talking about
absolutely can you draw like in there if
you like open it up as though
adventurous the King oh so long as they
intersect with all three lines yes
though I will point out if you do make
them cross somewhere in here what we're
going to demonstrate will be a bit
harder so I sort of more want you to
vary like the proportions and which way
these lines face but it'll be easier and
simpler if they don't okay right now
once you've done that here's what I want
you to compare and you're actually going
to have to measure these things do it as
closely as you possibly can what I want
you to compare is the fraction a C over
C Eve so your inner needs measure that
little spot of it and this length over
here and then divide those and then I'd
also like you to measure and calculate B
D over D F as accurately as you possibly
can you'll need a calculator obviously
cuz you get some weird gnarly numbers go
ahead and calculate those
and then I want you to compare them with
the numbers of the person next to you
once that person for sir has that done
I'll give you two or three minutes to
finish your drawing do some measurements
and then catch up with me okay
yeah yeah actually don't know do I
mm-hmm
you already have tutorial done yeah
sometimes you need it sometimes you need
to I mean generally of course we avoid
it if we can because often different
spots within excuse me the diagram can
be described in terms of the variables
you've already got I should take
pronumerals but that doesn't mean you
can't like there's a rule against it
sometimes you just have no choice I'm
going to suggest you though you know
exactly what the size of data is you
don't need to give it a name we should
have a look at your diagram and
particularly think about what kinds of
shapes you've got there you know more
about this shape than you realize okay
also it is like floating around there is
it on the no it's floating around the
middle 45 I've vetted bicycle riding or
you could say it's a bit already
birthday sometimes don't give it a name
you know you - it's a number you can
work out where just so you'd say angle
da da da equals angle da da da because
what and you tell me what's the reason
that they are equal to each other and
then because they add up to 90 they're
each 45
has anyone got the numbers so there are
got their own numbers yeah have you
compared with the person next to you yet
get it in the decimal get it as a
decimal you use what do you want yep
you can do it my if you like okay can I
get a show of hands who's taking their
measurements and has their ratios hands
up straight hands on straight I'm still
looking for some hands like your hands
down
I've got about half of you if you're not
done yet that's okay you'll probably be
able to as I speak get far enough into
this that you can work out what on earth
is happening here okay Jake so I did
this earlier I am I marked it all that I
used the ruler etc and I was measuring I
happen to measuring in millimeters but
maybe you have centimeters or something
else well on this ruler here I think you
can go to the half millimeter but I
didn't have that much precision at my
desk when you do the comparison that I
asked you to do you should find that
these numbers are eerily similar right
I'm you'll notice and I'm going to
encourage you to do this if you haven't
already I put approximately equal to for
both of these because you measured like
you measured with a physical instrument
there are always limitations on that
that's fine but they're not exact
they're not precise okay so what's going
on here okay the things that you've
measured each of these individual things
right this length this length this
length this length
we call them intercepts you've heard of
the word intervals before but it meant
something else it's meant a spot on a
corner axis right that's why you've got
an X in two
and away intercepts so in that context
on a Cartesian plane intercepts are
points but in this context that means
much less so intercept refer to these
are sections I suppose of these
intervals or lives okay so these things
that intercepts AE which cuts across a
parallel line parallel lines and B F
which also cut along these parallel
lines they're what we call the
transversals maybe you want to label
that as such these guys here are the
transversals which literally means they
cut across you know like transport gets
you across from one place to another so
these are the transversals these guys
are the intercepts on the transversals
and so there's something going on here
that's fishy can we prove what's going
on can we actually deductively using the
geometric skills and techniques that we
have access to not just measure and say
it looks pretty close but actually
conclusively in all cases not just the
25 that we just measured actually prove
it okay we can here's the approach we're
going to take grab your ruler again and
on the same diagram we're going to add
in a construction okay the construction
we're going to add in is the line that's
parallel to a e that passes through B
let me say that again we're going to
construct a line parallel to a e that
passes through B okay so I would write
this and this is going to be the proof
that you'll have beside your diagram
I'll write it like this construct
remember this new line of about is
construct goes through B so I'm going to
call it B something it's not to do with
these lines so I'm going to call it P
for point so I'm going to construct B P
such that B P is parallel to a just a
little minor point for you when you have
to make your own constructions on a
diagram when you draw that on your
diagram that's great but you've got to
say something like this you can't just
say construct B P because it's like well
what's special about be P what makes
that an important feature on your own
diagram and it's this feature that it's
parallel to an interesting line so if
you haven't already go ahead and draw
that in and let's also label it as such
okay we have created a new intercepts
over here so I need another name for
this so let's call this Q this guy down
here because they're clearly related to
each other okay now what I'm trying to
get toward is a relationship between
let's see here VD D F and AC C right
what I'm predicting is that these two
are equal to each other I don't know
that that's the case just yet right I
can't say that that's true that should
be my last line not my first line so
therefore what I'm going to put up here
is that what I'm required to prove is
that the two things are equal to each
other so that our TP just indicates yeah
I know that I don't actually have this
established yet that's where I'm going
to try and head now let me pause for a
moment I'm going to give you a clue and
then I'm going to ask you to work away
at this a little bit on your own okay I
want you to think about all the
knowledge that you've been using over
the last couple of weeks within geometry
okay
particularly have a look at the shape
that we've constructed what kind of
knowledge might be helpful and there's
many valid answers any takers any takers
say again there are going to be some
ratios they're going to be really
important that makes sense because the
thing we're trying to prove has to do
with ratios so first things first good
ratios where have we seen that most in
recent times what kind of shapes are
we've been working with that have ratios
in them similar triangles is where we've
been spending most our time do you see
some similar triangles you can see them
right we're going to need to prove that
they are because they look like it but
this is a person we want to show that
that's the case is there any other
important information that might be
useful to you hmm
Eric properties of quarter letters are
going to be very important so three
things number one ratios number two
similar triangles number three
properties are cordial at all I can tell
you which ones but there's somewhat
obvious from the diagram hopefully
there's three kind of um hooks to hang
your knowledge on this is where we're
going can you try and make a start
anywhere you like where are you going to
enter in how are you going to get to
here I'll give you about five minutes to
get a heads down on me and then I'll
show you my solution off you go